that cheeky devil Lucifer is back and
he's having one hell of a time on
Netflix yipee chimera lovers I'm John
and today I'm going to reveal some
devilish details about season four of
Lucifer including cool Easter eggs
ingenious foreshadowing secret cameos
and more things you may have missed
obviously spoilers ahead if you're not
all caught up if you were shocked by the
season 4 finale where Lucifer confessed
his love to Chloe then banished himself
from earth to sit on the throne in hell
then you'll be even more surprised to
know that that moment was cleverly
foreshadowed right in the opening scene
of the season the premiere episode began
with a montage of a lonely melancholy
Lucifer singing Radiohead's creep at his
club lurks Chloe's absence and the
throne like Art Deco background behind
Lucy predicts how he will end the season
alone again without Chloe sitting on a
throne overlooking Hell the reflection
of Lucifer in the piano also foreshadows
how split he'll feel this season between
his more and less devilish sides and
also how he'll travel from the earth
above to the underworld below and in a
really clever detail as the opening
montage plays out
Lucifer's clothes change with each new
day finishing with him in a white shirt
and dark suit with a little red
hankerchief in his breast pocket and
that's basically the same outfit
complete with red pocket square that we
see him wearing at the very end of the
season when he sat on his throne in hell
when Chloe visits father Kinley he shows
her a scrapbook of some of the problems
he says were caused by Lucifer's
previous visits to earth once we
uncovered Lucifer's identity we were
able to uncover evidence of his previous
visits with humanity you're saying he
caused the Chicago Fire and Nazi Germany
and when the detective turns to the page
of clippings from Nazi Germany was a
photo with non other than Lucifer
standing there however the devil does
not look impress with the people he
encountered and I think what father
Kinley is misunderstood is that
Lucifer's very likely there to find out
all about the humans he'll be punishing
late in hell in fact this links back to
previous mentions of Hitler on the show
how did you actually torture Hitler in
hell okay there was a talker well
screamer actually shouldn't you be
having tea with Hitler by now as for the
Chicago Fire well that's a cool Easter
Egg - one of actress Loren Germans
previous TV roles the
Chicago fire was a real fire that raged
for several days in late 1871 but of all
the historical events that the Lucifer
writers could have picked they chose
this one as lauren german AKA chloe
starred in two seasons of the TV drama
chicago fire where she played a
paramedic and it's tricky to make out
but there is a Lucifer Morningstar
listed on the check-in page with a hotel
in Chicago when Fox cancelled Lucifer
after its third season Lucy fans
responded with a resounding hell no and
got straight to work online letting
everyone know just how much the show
meant to them thanks to their online
campaign we got our deepest desire a
fiendishly good new season on Netflix
and there's a sly wink to the show's
former fate when Father Kinley hands
Lucifer his business card that's a can
investigator
sounds like a soon to be canceled TV
show and then a grateful shout-out to
those many fans who helped raise a
series from the dead the show's writers
titled episode 9 save Lucifer which is a
lovely hat tip to the hashtag Lucy fans
used to blow up Twitter there's a
particularly touching moment midway
through season four where a mana deal
tells Chloe just how proud her father is
of her and the way he says it it shows
that he's seen or spoken to her father
in heaven after all that you've been
through Chloe what you're worried about
most is what's best for those that you
care about no wonder your dad is so
proud of you that revelation is actually
a moving reminder of some of the final
words Chloe's police officer dad said
just before he was murdered just tell
her it was a good movie
kids these days yeah I know hey Pratt er
by the way the actor who played Chloe's
father in those flashbacks in season 2
is Chris Payne Gilbert the real-life
husband of lesley-ann Brandt who plays
maze speaking of maze she gets some
hilarious scenes as always in season 4
but there was one particularly
intriguing moment in the first episode
when she visits Linda when the doctor
encourages mazikeen to open up about her
guilt after hurting Trixie last season
the demon is more than a little
reluctant to discuss her emotions let's
talk about what your dealing was
emotionally yeah I really don't want to
go well maybe it'd help if I spoke your
language it used to be go on and even
maybe stun with
my nipples are made of bread and gone
what in a little shout-out to her
birthplace South Africa lesley-ann
Brandt has revealed that she was
speaking Afrikaans and if you are
wondering what she said well the
official Twitter account for Netflix
South Africa posted her Afrikaans
dialogue I put that into Google
Translate and here's what it means in
English and even maybe Dunham added bird
when they post on my joke gardening on
the role of Eve was actually written
with actress Ambala V in mind from the
start because one of Lucifer's writers
was a big fan of her starring role as a
con artist in the TV series imposters
and what a great choice she was as her
decision to go full-on playing the
original sinner Eve with all the
excitement and innocent wonder of a
Disney Princess with an extra naughty
side was absolute genius and there are
lots of lovely little touches and Eve
scenes from her drink of choice and
apple martini to the apples at the bar
and in other scenes then there's her
arrival in a heavenly white dress with a
killer pair of fiery heels to her later
appearances in clothing that's various
shades of red and there's even some
foreshadowing of where Lucifer and Eve's
new relationship is headed by the end of
the season in the lyrics of the song
playing just before Lucy discovers she's
back on earth also Eve's conversation
with father Kinley includes an amusing
nod to the opening lines of Catholic
confession forgive me Father for I have
sinned
forgive me Father I am Eve musics always
been a big part of the show and they've
been some great musical moments this
season kicking off with Lucifer back at
the piano singing his heart out to creep
Mays declaring her love to an oblivious
Eve by singing Wonderwall and Lucy Ella
and Dan getting their groove on in the
season finale with a little throwback to
dirty dancing indeed that toe-tapping
season finale could well pave the way
for a full-on musical episode next
season according to Co showrunner LD mod
revenge who's been eager to get the
Lucifer cast in full song and dance mode
for some time now and it looks like
actor Tom Ellis would definitely be up
for that because not only is last
season's luck be a lady tonight scene
one of his favorite moments in the show
so far but he's also said that the dance
sequence in the finale was his favorite
filming moment of season four by the way
we might never have heard Tom break into
song on the show if it hadn't
a cast and crew night out originally the
plan for the series was just for Lucifer
to play the piano but when the writers
heard tom belt out mustang sally' at a
karaoke bar they discovered their lead
actor could really sing and decided to
include it in the show remember the
sequence where amenadiel approaches
random strangers in an effort to connect
more with human beings now he's decided
to stay on earth
well when out of the blue he stops by
for a chat with a woman who's working on
her laptop in a coffee shop that woman
he's interrupting is actually played by
one of Lucifer's showrunners LD mod
revenge you also wrote this very episode
an ill DS Co showrunner Joe Henderson
snuck in an Easter Egg to another one of
his creations in the scene where Mays
and Trixie make up at the police
precinct Trixie is reading a comic book
called skyward all about The Adventures
of a young woman born into a low-gravity
world and Joe both wrote the comic book
and the episode disappears him Trixie's
previous reading material in the show
has also provided interesting Easter
eggs for example the book Coraline that
her mother read to her was written by
Neil Gaiman the co-creator of the
Sandman graphic novel which introduced
the Lucifer character that this TV
series is loosely based on so were there
any other cool details or Easter eggs
you spotted in season 4 and what were
your favorite moments tapleft for my
full breakdown in the season finale plus
my season 5 predictions or tap write for
another video you're sure to like
congratulations to the winner of the
last round my Avengers giveaway send me
a message from my about page so I can
send you the prize and if you enjoyed
this a thumbs up and a share are hugely
appreciated thanks for watching and see
you next time you became movie lovers